سأوضح لكم اليوم كيفية تحضير
جنوكتشي لذيذ مع صلصة اليقطين. زارا
عبد الله هي واحدة من العديد من المبدعين
الذين صنعوا اسمًا لأنفسهم في
دبي،
ونحن دائمًا في استوديو أضواء الكاميرا نشهد
ذلك إلى حد كبير في عام 2020.
كان واحدًا من 70 ألف شخص يعملون في
المجال الإبداعي بالمدينة، وهو رقم
تريد دبي مضاعفة بحلول عام 2025 كجزء من
استراتيجية جديدة مصممة لتنويع
اقتصادها. الهدف النهائي لدبي هو
إنشاء هذه المجموعة من المواهب
للتأكد من أن هذه الموهبة  نظرًا لأن المتعلم لديه
كل ما يتطلبه لإدارة
أعماله ثم يتحول هذا إلى
أعمال صحية ستساهم في المستقبل بشكل
إيجابي في
اقتصادنا، يعد الاقتصاد الإبداعي
أحد أسرع القطاعات نموًا في العالم
في عام 2022، وقد أفادت الأمم المتحدة
أنه يمثل  3.1% من
الناتج المحلي الإجمالي العالمي إدراكًا لهذه الإمكانات،
قدمت سياسة دبي الجديدة
تأشيرة ذهبية ثقافية خاصة لمنح أولئك مثل زارا
إقامة طويلة الأمد لتطوير
حياتهم المهنية في الإمارات،
يتيح لك النحل الذهبي الأمان، ويسمح لك
بالبقاء داخل المدينة لمدة 10 سنوات.  إنها
تضمن استدامة أعمالك، لقد
شعرت دائمًا أن هذه
مدينة انتقالية وبعد أن حصلنا على
التأشيرة الذهبية، أشعر حقًا أن دبي هي
موطن لتكرار هذا الشعور بالوطن
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين هم في الخارج، ويساعد هذا المخطط الجديد أيضًا في
إنشاء مراكز جديدة لجذب
المواهب الأجنبية  والاستثمار في
المنطقة الصناعية للتجاويف على سبيل المثال
يتم تجديده عندما نقوم بإنشاء
منصة مثل منطقة ألغوا الإبداعية التي
تسمح للأشخاص بالقدوم وإنشاءها
وتسمح بوظائف في
قطاع التصنيع. أحد رواد الأعمال الذين جذبهم هذا
المجتمع الفني المتنامي هو كوامي مينتا
باعتباره  وهو أحد مؤسسي معرض FEA
في أكوز، وهو يرى بشكل مباشر كيف
تغير خطة عمل المدينة نظرة العالم
إلى دبي،
فهي بمثابة وسيلة للوصول إلى
السيارة بين الفنانين
والاقتصاد الإبداعي هنا في دبي عندما يريد الفنانون
أن يصبحوا خصوصية دولية  لقد كانوا
يفكرون فقط في الذهاب إلى أوروبا أو
أمريكا ولكن الآن الشرق الأوسط
يفتح مجالاته بالفعل وهو
مشهد طبيعي كوجهة يرغب الفنانون في
عرض أعمالهم فيها حيث تعمل المدينة على رفع مساهمة
قطاعاتها الإبداعية في الناتج المحلي الإجمالي إلى
خمسة بالمائة  بحلول عام 2025، لن
يتمكن المبدعون المقيمون في دبي، مثل زارا، من الاستفادة إلا من
السياسات التي تحول الإمارة إلى
مركز عالمي للإبداع، فهي
تمنحنا مساحة للازدهار والشعور
وكأنك جزء من النسيج، ومن
المثير حقًا رؤية الجميع
يحتفل بهم من الأطباء و
المحامون ورجال الأعمال للطلاب
والفنانين والأشخاص
الذين لم يكن من الممكن أن يتم
الاحتفال بهم تقليديًا في هذا الجزء من العالم
[موسيقى]
أجنبية